today we're going to discuss the first
sign of kidney disease and actually this
will surprise you you know the kidney is
a filter and it converts blood into
urine and it's a fascinating piece of
your body because it's not just a little
passive filter it does a lot it recycles
all your fluids let's say you drink I
don't know eight glasses of water a day
now for those people in Europe
especially Dennis from Germany uh eight
glasses of water per day is roughly
about two liters and so if you drink
eight cups or two liters of fluid a day
you're going to pee out that amount
right throughout the day but think about
this
the amount of fluid that travels through
your kidney in a given day is a 180
liters that's 760 cups of fluid so
there's a lot of recycling going on in
the kidney it's a a magical recycler
because it recycles protein
nutrients hormones it recycles like 99
of all the water that you drink and so
we have this magical little filter that
has all these sensors that coordinate
the amount of fluid in your body that
help you convert vitamin D into the
active form of vitamin D to help
regulate your blood pressure and the
hydration of your body and the
elimination of toxins and drugs if you
really appreciate what that nephron the
filter of your kidney does for you
you probably are going to think twice
about eating junk food or or consuming
things that might harm the kidney
because it's an amazing amazing organ an
average person has between one million
to 1.5 million of these little filters
they're called nephrons and so when you
start developing kidney disease
the amount of nephrons starts to
decrease to the point where you might
end up with half of your nephrons and
also as you age you lose your nephrons
so we have a decreased ability to do all
this magic and filter out things there
is this one underlying most common cause
of kidney disease as well as end stage
renal failure and that relates to
diabetes it's called diabetic
nephropathy nephro meaning kidney apathy
meaning disease so it's this high blood
glucose situation that is the most
common reason why the kidney gets
destroyed and the mechanism of how this
filter gets destroyed is this when you
have high levels of sugar interacting
with these protein enzymes and other
protein structures
you start to get this reaction called
glycation and that's the morphing when
you have sugar and proteins okay it
starts to damage these proteins to the
point where they become unavailable and
the medical term for this is called
Advanced glycation end products so when
you have a lot of those you have a
combination of
um nephrons or these little filters that
don't work anymore or they're all gunked
up with protein that is stuck in there
and they can't filter and so the key
thing that they diagnose kidney disease
with is the amount of protein in your
urine because if we get less recycling
of the protein it ends up in your urines
not actually pulled into the body so
protein in the urine means there's a
kidney damage with that little filter
and also because it's ending up in the
urine there's going to be less protein
in your blood and that main symptom is
edema okay and it could be all over your
body is just filled with fluid so you'll
be puffing the face fluid in your hands
and your legs all over and the
interesting thing about kidney disease
is when the disease starts okay it takes
10 years sometimes before you even
notice the first symptom okay and so now
I'm going to tell you the first symptom
that a person will experience with
kidney disease it is nocturia now what
is nocturia
that is a situation where you're
urinating at night okay usually multiple
times and it's very difficult for you to
hold your urine throughout the night
that is one of the first signs that
means there's something going on with
your kidney and it makes a lot of sense
because the majority of diabetics also
have that same symptom and it also makes
sense because diabetes usually takes 10
years before you start noticing problems
so kidney problems go hand in hand with
diabetes and one thing about diabetes is
that it affects four tissues one is the
kidney okay which we're talking about
now next one is the eye next one is the
nervous system okay and then the
arteries and so with kidney problems
you're going to see protein in the urine
and you're going to see a decreased
filtration rate we no longer have the
filtering mechanism going on so we have
a lot of backup with toxins we have a
loss of a lot of nutrients including
amino acids then we get a lot lot of
Edema but because there's a huge delay
of 10 years it's difficult to identify
the cause and effect relationship but I
have found the most successful way to
get rid of this nocturium is just to
Simply handle the blood sugar situation
so let's talk about that for a second so
in medicine they will tell you that
diabetes is basically a situation where
you have poorly controlled blood sugar
levels so the key word with that is
controlled or they use this other term
called managed they manage the
complications of diabetes they manage
the symptoms of diabetes okay that's
kind of interesting you're going to
manage these complications and symptoms
but what about
correcting yeah you know they don't
really get into that why not manage or
control what the patient is actually
putting in their mouth and I'm talking
about sugar the amount of sugar or
carbohydrate that an average person
consumes in America
is astronomical if you especially if you
take all the hidden
carbohydrates like the breads the pasta
the cereal crackers you're talking a
massive amount of sugar right and it's
just so obvious why we have diabetics in
the world because they're consuming too
many carbohydrates yet the American
Diabetes Association uh still to this
day does not tell you how much carbs you
need to control they know there's a link
they know you need to reduce your carbs
which is great but they don't tell you
how much you should lower your carbs
instead there's all sorts of ways of
managing your blood sugar and the
complications what are the complications
well fluid retention so we can manage
that with a diuretic we also have high
cholesterol we can manage that with
statins we also have high blood pressure
we can manage that with high blood
pressure medication and of course the
blood sugars could be managed by
metformin and insulin and other
medications for diabetes but my question
is this
when you manage the blood sugars remove
the sugar out of the blood where does it
go is it just magically evaporate does
it just disappear it's just moved from
one place in the body to another place
it's moved from the blood into your
cells
into your liver around the organs
converted into fat I mean what about the
complications of all the medications
that you're using to manage these
complications from diabetes I mean just
it's just bizarre so whether you have
kidney problems or you want to prevent
kidney problems or you're getting up at
night right now urinating
um there's several things you can do to
turn this thing around the first thing
and the most obvious thing is to reduce
the amount of sugar in your bloodstream
okay that would mean going on a
ketogenic eating plan okay second thing
is doing intermittent fasting because
the less you eat the less you will raise
insulin the less insulin resistance
you'll have and the less diabetes you'll
have so those go hand in hand and the
type of intermittent fasting that I
would recommend is the type that I'm
doing right now which is one and a half
meals a day now what does that mean you
have your your big meal a little bit
afternoon or maybe right at noon okay so
you have your protein your fat
um and then later
I like to do it at three o'clock but
maybe you can do it later at six o'clock
you can you can call it your second meal
or your half a meal but you're not
really doing a lot of protein you're not
doing a lot of fat you're doing all your
vegetable carbohydrates okay and so what
I do right around three maybe three
Thirty at the very latest I'll have this
big salad with roughly about seven to
ten cups it's usually about 10 cups but
maybe you could do seven cups and it's a
big salad it's easy to eat I'm not going
to eat anything else so I have my
protein and fat at 12. and that three of
my big salad that way it's easier to eat
the salad because I could take my time I
do put various things in the salad I'll
definitely put olive oil sometimes I'll
use apple cider vinegar sometimes I use
balsamic vinaigrette I'll put little
seeds on that little nuts but it's
mainly greens and I might do different
types of greens I like to use arugula or
cabbage sometimes but if I'm doing
cabbage I'm not doing seven to ten cups
right so when you're doing more dense
vegetables you can do a lot less when I
talk about seven to ten cups I'm talking
about the lettuce leaves okay so that
seems to work really good I like it
because it gives me a very long fasting
period okay and am I hungry for that
salad no because I just ate you know a
few hours before but roughly it gives me
like 21 hours of fasting now a couple of
very important things about that salad
that I want to mention in relationship
to what we're talking about
you know people always talk about oh
yeah there's vitamins and minerals and
salad
um well there's also something very
important in relationship to the
complications of kidney disease and the
complications of diabetes and that is
phytonutrients okay phytonutrients have
all sorts of pretty cool properties but
the big one is nephro protection they
protect the kidney against oxidation and
complications of high blood sugar so if
you took two diabetics right and you
side to side and you gave one a diet
with low phytonutrients and you gave the
other one a diet high in phytonutrients
both of them would still be a diabetic
but the one with the phytonutrients
would have a lot less complications okay
so apparently these phytonutrients are
there they have antioxidant properties
they help reduce the oxidation they act
to neutralize a lot of the bad effects
of all this high glucose flowing through
your bloodstream so that's why you
should be consuming this large salad
every single day yes it has magnesium
and vitamin C and potassium which by the
way is very important for the kidney to
protect it of course the only time I
would recommend not doing it is if you
have end-stage kidney disease then you
have to get with your doctor but I'm
talking about potassium from the food so
plant phytonutrients are definitely on
the list the next thing I want to
mention and this is a remedy that you
can get and it's very powerful there's a
lot of research behind it it's called
benphotamine it's a type of vitamin B1
that is fat soluble and it really helps
reduce the common applications in a
powerful way of diabetes like I said
reduce the glycation effect decrease
oxidative stress and protect the cells
this is why benphotamine is really good
for peripheral neuropathy as well that's
the damage of the nerves in the bottom
of the feet as well as problems with
your eye called diabetic retinopathy but
it's also really good to decrease the
complications from diabetic nephropathy
okay damage to the kidney you basically
take one pill which I think is uh
usually like 300 milligrams four times a
day another thing that you could add if
you really wanted to it's not totally
necessary if you're doing all these
other things I'm recommending but alpha
lipoic acid is another powerful way to
decrease the complications from this
condition another thing you can use is a
turmeric okay
turmeric has this phytonutrient called
curcumin which is extremely potent and
decreasing the symptoms the signs the
complications of diabetes we want to
reduce the amount of carbohydrates and
we want to actually correct the
underlying problem and that's why keto
intermittent fasting are a necessity but
at the same time we can do some great
things by reducing all these other side
effects that are occurring because of
the high blood sugar as an experiment
okay if you're unwilling to lower your
carbohydrates maybe you just want to
prove it to yourself and see how these
other things can work by adding some of
these remedies to see how it can
actually reduce maybe even the need for
medication or the amount of medication
you're taking of course check with your
doctor but it can definitely help you so
anyway I just wanted to cover this topic
and give you some information that you
need to use if you have this problem and
I think if you are urinating at night
frequently this is exactly what I would
recommend now you might say well there's
no way that I'm a diabetic you know I
don't I have my blood pressure checked
well you should actually get a test
called Homa IR which measures the
insulin resistance which happens way
before diabetes but the point is there
is a connection between the
carbohydrates that you eat and nocturia
getting up in the middle of the night
and urinating now to have the right plan
in place to know what to eat and how to
do intermittent fasting I have my very
simple playlist up here you should check
this out right here